vote 2021 just don't call them the local
elections
here's why on may the 6th everyone in
scotland
england and wales but not northern
ireland goes to the polls
in elections that give us the first
glimpse of the electorate's mood
postcovid and post-brexit here's what's
up
in england 143 councils 35 police and
crime commissioners
13 mayors and the london assembly which
holds the mayor of london to account
now in scotland and wales the
parliaments are
up and for welsh police and crime
commissioners to beat
let's start with perhaps the most
important race in scotland where all 129
seats are up for election
and this is how it turned out last time
nicolas sturgeon's snp
almost getting the overall majority
target of 65 seats
can she do that this time or will she
have to rely on a party like the greens
in order to give her
a majority for an independence
referendum
then across england the biggest story of
the night like to be
the 50 million people who enact regional
or
metro mayors now here are the incumbents
you can recognize their faces
andy burnham in greater manchester
remember his fight with boris johnson
in the autumnal city khan in london who
out poles kierstarma
nationally but the really interesting
political ones are the tory ones now
look they're not
in traditional tory heartland but look
the tease valley and the west midlands
will be key to determining whether or
not kia stammer is winning back votes in
the red
wall and there's a new one up for grabs
in west yorkshire
now it's super thursday in england that
means
4 500 councillors elected in 143
different councils
21 county councils in places like
lincolnshire 35 metropolitan boroughs in
places like newcastle 28 unitary
authorities
big beast councils that any party would
want and 59 district authorities
the lifeblood of our local democracy but
if you want one seat to watch
then it should be this one derbyshire
now a long time labour council in 2017
the tories
took it outright it was at a low point
in jeremy corbyn's
libido ship can kirstama start to build
back
and if so you'll see it in places like
this then
wales now what you're looking at here is
the 2016 result where labour almost got
31 uh and a majority mark drakeford is
the first minister can he hang on
or will the labour vote be squeezed and
have have to rely on the nationalist
plaguery
given that there's a tory challenge
since the last time
uh this welsh poland was up for election
and finally
there's a by-election in hartlepool in
the north east
the red wall again can labour hang on
here's why it's so hard
in the 2019 general election label one
but only just in front of the tories who
are only just in front of the brexit
party and the brexit party
have changed their name where will these
votes go could they go to the tories and
could that give them enough support
to mean that they go into first place
this isn't a banker for kirstama
thursday may the sixth is the biggest
act of democratic renewal there's ever
been outside of a general election boris
johnson
and kiss tama both have good reasons to
be nervous